I want to take a few minutes today to talk
about some conspiracy theories that are very
antisemitic, which have been spreading in
some right wing circles and unfortunately
even in some left wing circles, which in short
are about blaming.
Suppose it Israeli billionaires and the word.
Suppose it is important and you'll know why
in a second. The theories are that Israeli
billionaires are really the interfering in
American elections. The gist is it's not Russians
that are interfering. It's not anybody else.
The people really interfering are so-called
Israeli billionaires, which of course is code
for the Jews. Now understand that these are
bad faith actors with a very thinly veiled
antisemitic agenda, uh, to, to create these
Jewish conspiracies about using money to control
things. These are, these are old antisemitic
tropes about Jews. We've been following on
those tropes on this show for a decade. But
let's look at how this all is coming together.
The most important thing to understand is
that there are almost no Israeli billionaires.
Okay. And even lots of the people that are
sometimes called Israeli billionaires really
sort of aren't Israeli in any realistic sense.
So if you want to figure out whether a conspiracy
theory has any merit, you have to, as I said
earlier this week, critically analyze primary
sources. So the first thing to figure out
is who are all of the Israeli billionaires?
Let's figure that out first and assemble Google
search. Turns up a list of 23 people, not
230 not 2300 not 23,000 there are 23 people
listed as Israeli billionaires at least nominally
as of 2018 we are talking here about a list
that is at the most 23 people, but I encourage
you to go beyond just the list, look closely
at this list and you will realize a lot of
these people aren't even really Israeli in
any sense other than holding citizenship,
which is available to any Jewish person who
wants it. I was born in Argentina. I came
to the U S at age five I could go and spend
a year in Israel.
I think it takes about a year and I can get
Israeli citizenship and then I could move
right back to the U S would I be Israeli in
terms of the defining characteristic of a
mind now in Israeli television host? No, I'm
not. So there are nominally 23 Israeli billionaires,
but over the 23, you look at a lot of them
and they're not really Israeli, right robe
Roman Abramovich from Lithuania lives in the
UK from Lithuania lives in the UK. Okay. He
has Israeli citizenship but not really what
you think of when you think of an Israeli
billionaire. Neither born there, uh, nor lives
there. A y'all offer. Certainly born in Israel
has been living in Monaco for a long time.
Patrick [inaudible] Moroccan family moved
to France, lives in Switzerland. He has Israeli
citizenship. It's not really an Israeli billionaire
in any relevant sense. Eden offer Romanian
born, lived in Israel for a little while,
made his money in Asia and the United States,
not even sure where he lives now.
It could be the U S could be London. That
really in his Railey billionaire in the sense
that the conspiracy theorists want us to believe.
One more example. Um, hi, I'm subhan born
in Egypt, went to Israel, has been living
in Beverly Hills for a very, very long time.
Is that really what we're talking about when
we say Israeli billionaire? So my point is,
even on the merits, you start with a list
of 23 suppose it Israeli billionaires, you
very quickly see that roughly half or more
don't even really fit the definition. And
then very rapidly the conspiracy theory on
which this is all built falls apart. Now there's
one other angle to this that I want to mention.
Some of these supposedly Israeli billionaires,
as I told you, live in the United States,
they're really American in practical terms.
Some of them might get involved in politics
as everyone has a right to do who is an American
citizen.
So once you're talking about, well when you
say Israeli billionaires, are you talking
about just Americans? Americans who live in
the United States and have American citizenship,
they are getting involved in politics. That's
part of the system we have. It's a broken
system, right? The system we have for how
politics is financed is disgustingly corrupt.
It's completely broken. But to single out
individuals who held or hold Israeli citizenship,
but who really are Americans as the real conspiracy
is a very thinly veiled antisemitic trope
and we shouldn't fall for it. And when anyone
else gets involved in politics in the country
where they live, it's called participating
in the election. When a handful of rich Jews
do it, it's Israeli billionaires conspiring
to influence elections. It's pathetic. It's
transparent, but sadly it works on a lot of
people and it's being used as the shiny thing
to take your attention away from real election
interference, real voter suppression, real
purges of the voter rolls and all of the other
things that we've been talking about on this
program for the last three years. In one month
of Donald Trump's presidency. Don't fall for
it. Don't fall for it. Let me know what you
think. I'm on Twitter at deep Pacman. Make
sure you're following me. Follow the show
on Twitter at David Pakman show. We have a
hell
of a
Friday show for you today